let's face it ladies and gentlemen we
live in a 24-hour news cycle there is so
much breaking news it's kind of hard to
process all of it well we found a way to
put the day's news in perspective
quickly with the help of our good friend
Deon Cole let's do that right now let's
see here's a story this week House
Speaker John Boehner asked Hillary
Clinton to turn in her personal web
server as part of an ongoing
investigation Coenen were you on your
computer last night yeah I was yeah and
did you look at some page you didn't
want other people to see yeah I think I
did you tell Bain and a man his business
to shut the hell up okay
[Music]
there's another story this week
Ireland's Prime Minister and you Kenny
criticized Australia's Prime Minister
from playing that Irish culture is
synonymous with alcohol what is it will
you call what do you call when you put
whiskey and coffee
that's called an Irish Coffee and when
you drink all night next to a dead body
what does that call an Irish wake and
what do you call a dance that looks like
a police sobriety test Irish
step-dancing then you tell that Irish
guy to grab a Guinness
[Applause]
[Music]
this week the military government of
Thailand bans citizens from posting
pictures of underboob on Twitter and
Instagram they say it corrupts the
morals of the population is this a
picture of a Buddha from Thailand
yes yes it is and what is he someone
he's showing underboob hello okay
[Applause]
[Music]
finally on Monday Starbucks CEO Howard
Schultz urged baristas at Starbucks to
write the phrase race together on
people's coffee cups and invite
customers to talk about race with
Starbucks employees are white people
creating a line before they even had a
coffee yes they are it's a black man
that's in line talking about his
oppression with his people gonna make
them cranky white people cranky
probably yeah he's probably then you
tell Howard shorts I said spell my name
right all my club and kids my venti
mocha sweet caramel double chocolate
[Applause]
[Applause]
here on call everybody get on Korra
[Music]
great show tonight I'm absolutely
thrilled one of my favorite actors this
year from the new movie the gunman
academy award-winning actor Sean Penn
all right coming up next yeah from
shameless in the TNT series Rizzoli and
Isles Sasha Alexander's on the show
I want to do a whole show where I'm back
here and you're up there let's do that
sometime comedian Dana Gould is on the
show
[Applause]
you
you